All right, I think we're ready to get
started.
Can the people in the Zoom meeting hear
me?
Great.
Okay.
All right, let's pick up where we left
off yesterday.
Uh so or or on Wednesday rather.
Um so when we wrapped up on Wednesday,
we were just starting to talk about uh
this notion of um of happens before. And
we introduced this this notation, right?
Of uh of A arrow B.
Uh which is pronounced
A happens before B.
Uh and we said that that what uh what it
means when we know that A happened B uh
is that A could have been the cause of
B, right? Uh but B could not have been
the cause of A. And this is very
important in uh
being able to reason about how to debug
and design distributed systems.
Uh but in the drawings that I did
yesterday, uh
when we were drawing uh machines and
messages going uh between machines and
so on like this,
uh
the trouble with this kind of drawing is
that it you you can't really tell which
of those messages happened first just by
looking at the drawing, right? So,
what we can do is actually make time
explicit in the drawings that we do. And
so we're going to introduce a a new way
of drawing diagrams today uh that allows
us to talk about what happened before
what.
And so for that um so we're going to
mostly not use this style of drawing uh
and we're instead going to introduce uh
a new style of drawing uh which we're
going to call
Lamport diagrams.
Also known as
space-time
diagrams.
So the idea
of a Lamport diagram uh is that we have
a notion of a of a process.
And a process is just a line
with a discrete beginning
that goes on
forever.
And events
are going to be dots on the line.
So,
let's think of this line as representing
a process and let's think of these dots
as representing events on the line uh
and time goes this way.
So,
let's say I pick two dots on the line.
Say I pick two events on the line. Say X
and Z.
Could X have caused Z?
Sure. Yeah, X could have caused Z. It
happened before Z in that process.
Uh could Z have caused X?
No, Z couldn't have caused X.
But do we know for sure that X caused Z?
No, we don't.
We don't know for sure that X caused Z.
So,
but we can use this tool of of um
processes uh represented by lines and
events in those processes represented by
dots on the line uh
to uh
to to talk about what might have caused
what, right? So, given an event,
all I have to do to find
the set of events that might have caused
it is look above it on the line.
If I want to know why an event happened,
something that's above it on the line
was somehow responsible for that.
Um but of course it's not that simple,
right? Cuz we don't have this one
machine. Uh we have multiple machines.
Uh so so let's make this a little bit
more interesting, right? Um instead of
just one process line,
let's have more than one.
Um so let's say that we have uh
say we have
machine zero and machine one and machine
two.
So,
maybe on on machine one we have our
events uh X, Y, and Z.
Um but then there's all kinds of other
events that are occurring. Uh
so maybe um
uh
on machine two there's an event P.
And on machine zero there's an event Q.
Uh
and furthermore,
because these machines don't share any
memory and can't read each other's
minds,
they have to communicate by sending and
receiving messages. In fact, that's the
only way that these machines can
communicate with one another by by
sending and receiving messages.
Uh
and message sends and receives are also
events. In fact, they're very important
kinds of events.
Uh so we can start to add some messages
to this picture as well. Um so let's say
that this this event here P
is actually a message send. So let's say
that this is a send.
And let's say that we have an event over
here
that's a message receive.
And let's say we have another send and
receive here.
Maybe another one.
So now we've got a whole bunch of events
in this picture. Some of them are just a
um what we call internal events. Uh
events that are internal to a particular
process line.
And then some of them are message send
and receive events. So P for example is
a message send and T is a message send
and U here is a message send. Uh
and then S is a message receive and Q is
a message receive and R is a message
receive.
And then events like I guess X and Y and
Z and V here are uh internal events.
So,
using this picture
uh as a guide, let's try to come up with
a general definition for when one event
happens before another event.
Um
so we already covered part of it, right?
Uh we said that uh
when we were dealing with just just a
single process line uh like this,
um
then we said that if event an event
happens before another event on the same
process line or if it occurs higher than
that event on that process line, then we
know like that X happened before Z for
example.
Um so that's going to be the first part
of our definition.
Uh so let's write this out. And I'll
move back and forth between this
definition and and this picture that I'm
showing right now.
Um so we want to say
um
given two events A and B,
we say
A happened before B. Recall that this is
this notation here of the arrow A arrow
B is just pronounced A happened before
B.
We say that A happened before B
uh
if any
of the following is true.
First one is the one that we've already
talked about. So,
A
and B occur on the same process line.
With B after A.
So that's the first part of the
definition. Uh but there's more.
Um does anybody want to guess uh what
other conditions uh
under what other conditions we can say A
happened before B?
Right.
Uh so so how could we could we write
that down?
Mhm.
Well, let's let's just handle the
situation of sends and receives first.
Uh I think you're actually uh jumping
ahead. So, um so so
one way
uh for us to say that one event happened
before another, right? Is let's let's
look at, you know, U and R here in this
picture.
U is a send and R is a receive, so U had
to have happened before R, right? You
can't uh
uh you can't receive a message before it
was sent.
Uh
Right, and we're writing the definition
right now.
So so yeah, so we can say
uh for the next part of addition of
definition, we can say A
is a message send
event
and B is the corresponding receive.
All right.
Great.
So, we already know
a lot of our happens before
relationships. Uh so, we know that, you
know,
X happened before S, S happened before
Y, X happened before Y. Uh we know that
P happened before R. Um and we know that
uh that message sends happened before
their corresponding receives. So, we
know that P happened before S. Uh and so
on. But, we're not done. Um there's one
more part to this definition. Uh
uh which might have been kind of what
the this last question was anticipating.
Um
and so um
uh somebody in chat has actually already
anticipated it. And so, the last part is
uh the part that that makes this a
transitive relation.
So, we say that if A happens
before
some other event uh C
and C happens before some other event
um
B
cuz A and B are the two that we're
talking about.
Um
then A happens before B.
So, this last part here
is what makes it uh a transitive
relation.
We call this the transitive closure
of the of the relation.
Uh so, to look at that at our picture
here
um
So, for example, uh let's look at two
events. Let's say P
uh and Y.
So, we know that P happens before S,
right? Because P is a send and S is the
receive.
We know that S happens before Y because
they're on the same line. And so, we can
put those two pieces together
um using that transitive closure idea
and see that P happened before Y.
And so, this I this is a very powerful
way of reasoning about
uh what happened before what in a
system.
Um now, importantly, it doesn't give us
a way to relate all events in the system
to each other, right? Uh there are some
events in here where uh we can't use
those three rules that I just wrote down
uh
to necessarily give those events an
order.
Um
but we'll talk more about that later.
Um so, this is the definition of the
happens before relation.
This is not actually uh
an algorithm exactly for computing the
happens before relation. Later on, we'll
talk about ways to compute uh what is in
the happens before relation for some set
of events. Um so, if we see some event,
we'll be able to figure out what events
happened before it, and we know that the
cause of that event must be somewhere in
that set of events that happened before
it.
Uh but, we'll talk uh more about
actually to how to how to actually
compute uh the happens before relation
later on.
Um so, here is uh a classic Lamport
diagram.
And it involves some some strong
language.
So, let's say we have Alice and Bob
and Carol.
And
they're each uh process.
Um and let's say that Alice sends a
message
um to both Bob and Carol.
And let's say this message is
Bob smells.
So, Bob gets this message, right? And uh
he can't really let that stand, right?
So, Bob has to say something in
response. So,
So so Bob says, "Fuck you, Alice."
Well,
look what's happening for Carol here,
right?
Carol gets this FU message.
And
she hasn't seen this original message of
Bob smells yet. So, Carol is super
confused right here.
This is what's known as a causal
anomaly.
So, generally speaking, anomalies are
are things that make you go, "Huh?" like
Carol is in this example.
So, we're going to talk about how we can
use the concept of happens before to
rule out such anomalies.
So, if you if you look at what went on
here, um you can see that this Bob
smells message
kind of took a while to get to Carol. Um
why? Why did it take so long to get to
Carol?
Sure.
Yeah, so there could be any number of
reasons, right? Which we talked about
last time. So, recall that we we defined
a distributed system as one that
experiences unbounded latency.
Um so, if we're not careful in designing
our systems,
latency will lead to bugs. Um actually,
latency is going to lead to problems no
matter what uh since certain problems
are literally impossible to avoid in a
setting of unbounded latency.
Um but this this brings us to uh
uh to to something else that I want to
discuss, which is called network models.
Um so, it would really make life easy
if we knew that there was some fixed
amount of time that it took um for a
message to get from Alice uh to the
intended recipient. Um it would it it
would sure make it easy to build a
system that avoids this kind of bug uh
if we had that kind of guarantee. Uh
Does anybody know what that kind of a
system is called when we when we know
that there is some fixed amount of time
that it takes uh for a message to get
where it gets?
What what that kind of a network is
called?
A synchronous network.
So, synchronous networks do exist.
Um they aren't the kind that we're going
to be spending most of our time talking
about in this course.
Uh but, they're worth mentioning at
least briefly. So, to be precise, uh a
synchronous network uh is one
where
there exists
an
an N
some number N
such that
no message
takes longer than N units of time
to be delivered.
Um So, syn- synchronous networks do
exist. Uh
um a synchronous network for for a for a
message to be uh
synchronous um
there there typically has to be um
some sort of stable circuit between the
sender and the receiver.
Uh
but we're not going to be talking much
about synchronous networks uh in this
course.
Uh so these are this is this is one
network model.
Uh
we're going to spend most of our time uh
talking about uh another network model.
The asynchronous network model.
So
what's an asynchronous network? Uh
an asynchronous network is just a
network where there exists no such n.
Uh so some folks are asking some good
questions in chat. Um one question is
could an asynchronous network work as a
synchronous network for for large values
of n? Uh so
often when people build systems, they
they make simplifying assumptions,
right? So you might indeed when you're
building a system uh decide to assume uh
that it does behave synchronously uh for
some uh large n. And in fact uh if you
want to on on your own, you can look up
partially synchronous
uh networks.
Um
uh Nancy Lynch book called um
uh distributed algorithms.
Where I think she has a a definition of
this.
Um
I we're not necessarily going to talk so
much about partially synchronous uh
uh because I I I don't want to confuse
things too much. Um but yes, uh in
practice people make simplifying
assumptions all the time about the the
behavior of of networks. Um
but um
in general
you can't assume that there is a
particular n that a message is
definitely not going to take longer than
that n to be delivered on the internet.
Um
so both of these when I say network
model, uh a model is something is a set
of assumptions that you use to build a
system. Uh those assumptions might be
more or less realistic. Uh but you can't
build a system at all unless you you
figure out what your assumptions are.
So uh so you need to decide are we going
to assume that we have an an
asynchronous network or or are we going
to assume that we have a synchronous
network?
Uh and if I'm asking you to implement uh
some sort of distributed protocol
um I haven't really told you what a
protocol is yet, but um let's just say a
protocol is a is a set of rules that
computers use to communicate with each
other.
If I ask you to implement a protocol
and you need to pick a a network model
to work with
um
if you really want to ensure that your
protocol is robust
uh then you should pick the asynchronous
network model to work with, the least
forgiving protocol.
Uh
because you really want to um
uh you you you want you want to pick the
model that will have the the the fewest
sort of sort of assumptions.
On the other hand, um let's say that I
want you to prove that something is
impossible.
Um that I want to prove that some
behavior in a system is impossible. Um
this is something that that Nancy Lynch
does a lot, for example.
Um in that case, what network model
should you go for?
Um so in that case, you actually want to
pick the friendliest, most forgiving
protocol. Um because
you want your impossibility result to be
as strong as possible, right? So if your
impossibility result shows that
something's impossible even in the most
forgiving environment um then you know
that it's going to be impossible in the
others, too. So if I show that something
is possible it is impossible uh even in
the synchronous network model, then
surely it's also going to be impossible
in the asynchronous network model, uh
which is which is less forgiving.
Um so those are network models. Uh in
this course, we're going to spend most
of our time uh assuming that our
networks are are asynchronous. Um
whether this is a
a a realistic assumption in daily life
uh is kind of another question.
Um so a question in chat, uh what do I
mean by friendly? Um the friendliest,
most forgiving protocol is is the the
protocol that kind of makes the most uh
assumptions uh
that that make reasoning easier.
Um so so again, like if we were trying
to to to prove that some behavior uh
in a um in a distributed system was was
impossible um
if we if if if we prove that that um
uh or or or prove that some prove that
something was impossible in a
distributed system. Uh
if we prove that's impossible even even
if we know that messages take no longer
than n units of time to to be delivered
uh then we know it would also be
impossible in this other setting where
there is no bound on n.
Okay, so I think we're going to uh pause
and do a quiz question.
So for those who are
uh
in chat I will share the link to the
quiz question.
And we'll take a few minutes to do that.
About 20 responses to the quiz so far.
We'll wait a few minutes longer.
So for those of you watching on Twitch,
this is the part where I ask my students
uh in my class to do a quiz.
Uh like a one question quiz.
Uh but what I should actually do is show
the the the quiz question on the stream
as well. So I'll figure out how to do
that next time.
All right, we're at almost 100 responses
to the quiz, so uh I think that's
probably good enough. We'll leave it
open for a little while longer, uh but
I'll I'll move on. Uh so, uh
uh let's talk about something else. Uh
let's talk about state
and events.
Um so, we said that a dot
on a Lamport diagram is an event, right?
Um but we didn't talk about state at
all, right? Like, what if this process
um has some state? Before, when we were
talking about uh messages between
machines M1 and M2, uh we said that M1
was asking a question, right? About
about the value of X, and we were saying
that M2 happened to know or believe that
that X was five.
Uh so, there isn't really anything in
this picture over here um that captures
that, right? That captures this um this
X equals five, this piece of state. Um
so, you know, if you wanted to, you
could kind of just like write it down
right here. You could say, "Oh, this
this um this process happens to be M1 or
M2, rather. Maybe M1 is over here."
And then the way that this exchange of
messages might look would be like this.
And then if all goes well, M2 is going
to respond with the answer.
Um
but what I what I would argue to you uh
is that
let Well, let's talk about what state
means, right? Um
what what is a state that a machine can
be in? Um like, when you when you study
computer architecture, for example, um
uh
what do you what do you say that a state
is?
You know, I didn't say wrong answers
only. All right. Um so,
uh
what I was going to say is that the the
state that a machine is in is something
like the contents of the memory and the
registers and so on.
Um
so, that's the state of one machine, but
in this world where where events occur
on a timeline like this, how how are we
supposed to talk about state? Um so, I'm
going to argue that a dot on one of
these diagrams is also a state
uh in the sense that
whatever the contents of a computer's
memory are at some point is going to be
completely determined by all the events
that have happened up until then. Um so,
if M2 knows that X is five, that means
that there had to be some sort of an
event somewhere on this process line,
you know, maybe it was an internal event
um
that made X be five.
Um so, a point is an event,
but it also represents a state.
And we can always work out what state
that we're in by looking back at at the
events that have occurred.
Um so, one way to represent the state
that we're in
is by looking at this sequence of
events.
Uh so, we can always work out what state
we're in. So, in principle, you know, if
I knew that all the history of events
that occurred on M2, um I wouldn't even
have to write this down, right? Um
because this this fact of of X is
currently set to five would be
represented um
either by an event, you know, maybe this
was the event that set X to five,
or maybe um there was some event that
set X to one, and then there were four
events that each incremented X by one uh
that were all internal events. Um but
whatever it was, um
there was some some sequence of events
that sort of boiled down to being a
state.
So, a point is an event, but it's also a
state, and we can always work out what
state that we're in by looking back at
events.
Um
is it possible to do the reverse? If we
know right now um that X is five,
uh is it possible to work out what
sequence of events led to that?
Uh with limited resources, probably not.
So, that's kind of all I want to say
about state and events. Uh when we do
these diagrams, uh we are often actually
going to write down little bits of state
uh
like this, X equals five,
uh on the diagrams themselves. Um
but just think of that as a sort of
shorthand for some actual sequence of
events. So, this sort of diagram is
actually very very expressive, and if we
wanted to, uh we could represent uh
everything that ever happened uh just
using this this visual language of
process lines and messages and events.
Um so,
this uh this piece of state that I'm
writing down up here, um this X equals
five, uh just think of it as a shorthand
for something that I could have
expressed using uh this um
uh this this very simple visual
language.
Okay.
So, I think probably everybody who was
going to respond to the quiz has
responded, so I'm going to close the
quiz now.
And let's let's just quickly recap um
uh
the definition of happens before. Um
so, uh
in chat, um let's let's just define
the three pieces of the happens before
relation. Um
so, uh somebody blurted out um
what are parts one, two, and three of
this relation?
Yeah, let's say so so, A and B are
actually events.
So, we don't say A receives a message
from B. Um we talk about processes
receiving messages from each other. Um
uh but we're going to say A and B are
events. Uh but you're on the right
track. So, we say, "If A is a send
and B
is the corresponding receive,
then we know that A happened before B."
Okay, what else?
Good. Yep, so.
Okay, and then what's the last part?
Last part is the part Yeah, go ahead.
Right.
Sure.
So, that is what allows us to kind of
put together the other pieces, right?
So, if you have uh say M1 and M2 here,
and you have some events um
that happen on those uh processes,
uh and let's say so, let's say you have
like event X here,
and events Y and Z here,
um and X happens to be a send,
and Y is a receive,
um then
uh
we know that X happened before Y,
because that's this uh
this second part of the definition.
We know that Y happened before Z,
because that's the first part of the
definition.
And then the the third part of the
definition, that this um
this transitive closure piece allows us
to sort of glue together
those first two parts of the definition
uh to conclude that uh X happens before
Z.
And then this this keeps going, right?
So we could have more events here.
Uh
um
So if we have another event here, we
know that Y happens before Q. Um and we
know that X happens before Q. We knew
that X happened before Q anyway, because
they're on the same line. Uh but we also
have this other path by which uh X
happened before Q as well.
So
uh So this is the definition of that of
the happens before relation. Um
So this I haven't I'm not being
completely precise here actually. Um so
I've so I've written down three
different ways uh that events can be in
the happens before relation. Um so so
strictly speaking, um it's uh it's
actually uh
um
it's it's a it's a little bit uh uh more
precise than that. Um it's it's we say
that it's the
um
the smallest
relation
such that this is true.
Um So so what do I mean by smallest
relation?
Um so
this page is getting a little crowded,
so let's switch to a new one. Um
So
a relation, a binary relation like the
one that that I'm talking about, um
is is actually just a set of ordered
pairs.
Um so if we're talking about um some set
of events, let's say. Um
So
putting some events here, let's just say
that we have
A B C
um
and D.
Uh let's say that these are the the
events that we have. Um so let's just
try to write down um the happens before
relation. And by that I just mean the
set of pairs of events that are related
by this but by this happens before
relation.
Um so what are they? Well, okay. Well,
we know that A happens before B, right?
Because um because A is a send and B is
the receive. Um so we can we can put
that pair.
Um
And then we know that B happens before
C, right?
Because B is uh
before C on the same process line.
Um and then we know that A happens
before C because of transitivity.
Um
And we know that D happens before C,
right?
Uh because D is a send and C is a
receive.
Uh
Is that it or did I miss any?
Ah, so somebody asks in chat um
uh should A D be in there?
Did A happen before D?
Do we know that?
Yeah, so we don't know that.
Um there's there's maybe it did, right?
But we don't know for sure that it did.
Um maybe it kind of looks like it did,
right? Because I kind of if if this is
time in this direction,
then it looks like D appears a little
bit lower than A in this picture. So it
might indeed look as though D happened
before A. Um but our definition of
happens before
does not
uh does not tell us anything about
whether A happened before
uh D.
So this pair is actually not part of of
the the happens before relation um for
this. So uh for this particular set of
events.
Um
So so this gets back to to um to what I
was saying about smallest relation. So
so we said that there were three
conditions under um un- under which um
uh
uh a pair of events could could it be
included in in the happens before
relation. So the the three uh
possibilities, just to represent them
vis- visually, are either the events are
on the same process line
or
one of the events is a send and the
other event is the corresponding receive
or
it's the transitive closure of the of of
of those things.
So those are those are the
possibilities. Um
uh but we say that the happens before
relation is the smallest relation. And
so if if you think of a relation is just
being a set of pairs, I'm saying the
set, the smallest set such that all of
these things are included in it.
Uh so
if I didn't have that condition that it
had to be the smallest relation such
that all these things are included in
it, then I could say, "Oh, well,
okay, I've got all these things covered,
but then I'm also going to throw all
kinds of other garbage in my happens
before relation as well. Uh and it'll
still uh it'll still check all the
checkboxes. It'll just also have other
stuff in it as well."
So we actually don't uh
we don't want to be that loose in
defining what happens before means. Uh
because then um
uh because then stuff will be included
in the happens before relation that we
don't want. So that's that's why if
we're being pedantic about it, we have
to say we have to say that the happens
before relation is the smallest relation
such that these three conditions are
true.
Okay.
So let's
do a few examples
and think about what happens before
what.
So I'll bring back the picture that I
had a little while ago.
If I can find it.
Here we go.
All right.
So
let's look at this and let's just try to
talk about what happened before what.
Um So if I I'm I'm going to pick out two
events. Um
and uh and you you tell me if they're
related by the happens before relation.
Um So how about uh
P
and
S.
Are those related by happens before?
Sure.
Okay.
Okay. What about X and Z?
Yeah, those ones are as well. Okay. How
about P and Z?
Yeah, those are as well. Uh
by transitivity, right? Cuz we can get
from P to S to Y to T to Z here.
Um How about
Q and R?
Those are not related by the happens
before relation.
Uh and so by that I mean, it's not true
that Q happened before R.
But it's also not true that R happened
before Q.
So
we can write that this way. We can write
the line with a slash through it.
When this is the case for two events,
we say that they're concurrent.
And another way that's written is to to
put a double line between them.
So sometimes people write it like this.
And another word we use to describe it
uh when they're concurrent is we we say
that they're independent.
Questions about this?
Okay.
So, we have about 15 minutes left. Uh I
want to talk a little bit uh about
partial orders.
So,
this relation that we've been talking
about uh this happens before relation uh
is a is a particular kind of relation.
Uh it's called a partial order.
Um
It's actually a special kind of partial
order.
Um
Uh but we'll get more into that later.
So, uh
can somebody who's uh uh maybe maybe
taken uh a math class that studied this
uh tell me what the definition of a of a
partial order is?
Some people are typing, so I'll be
patient.
You know, one thing about running class
online is that it's possible to just
paste a Wikipedia definition, isn't it?
Um yeah, so
maybe we can come up with a definition
that's that's uh
that's slightly more more intuitive. Um
so, so a partial order is actually two
things glued together.
Um
Uh so, first um
uh it's a set.
Um let's call it S.
And then
that set comes together with something.
A binary relation
usually
but not always
written
like this. So, something that looks like
less than or equal.
That lets you compare things.
From the set S.
And it has to have the following
properties.
Does anybody know this? What are the
properties that a uh
that that a that the binary relation in
a partial order has to have? Can
somebody tell me what what one of them
is?
Um so,
actually somebody just said what the the
word that I was looking for in chat. Um
so, reflexivity.
What does that mean?
Um it means that uh
for all
A
that are in the set S
A is less than or equal to A.
Um what else? What else does a uh
does a partial order have to be?
Yeah, you can compare an item to itself,
sure. And it's uh um an item is less
than or equal to itself.
Okay, transitivity.
Um let's put that one last.
So, this says that
um
So, I should put a for all up here.
So, for all
um
A
B and C in the set S
this is uh
I'm not sure if you can read my writing
or not, but this uh this symbol right
here is is uh this symbol right here is
the symbol for in. So, I'm saying that
A, B, and C are in S or in are members
of S.
So, transitivity says that
if A
is related to B
and B is related to C
then
A is related to C.
That's what transitivity says.
Um what's what am I missing?
Yeah.
Something called antisymmetry.
Yeah. And what does antisymmetry say?
It says that
if we're talking about A and B
So, this is actually um
um
another way to put this.
Um
is to say that
if A is less than or equal to B
and B is less than or equal to A
then A equals B.
So, if we're going to say that
A and B are related in this way and then
also swapped around if B and A are
related by the relation, then A and B
have to be the same thing.
Uh so, those are the properties that
have to have to be true of a partial
order.
Um I just claimed that the happens
before relation is a partial order.
But
the happens before relation is actually
uh a little bit weird, right? Because if
we try to think about the happens before
relation uh which is a relation on
events
uh and we try to think about how that
fits together with this definition that
I just wrote down. Um
it's probably going to seem a little
strange, right?
Because a partial order is supposed to
be reflexive, right? Um So,
uh a classic example of the partial of a
partial order uh
is just uh this plain old less than or
equal to relationship on uh let's say
natural numbers, right? Um so, this is
this is true of natural numbers, right?
If we pick say the number three, right?
Three is less than or equal to three.
That is true, right? Three is also equal
to three. Um but that means that three
is less than or equal to three.
But if we're talking about events in a
distributed system
uh
if we're talking about um
uh the happens before relation on events
it doesn't make any sense to say that an
event A happens before A, right?
And so, the happens before relation is
actually not reflexive.
And so, the happens before relation is a
weird partial order that does not
actually uh
uh respect these rules. We say that the
happens before relation is an
irreflexive
partial order. And so, I actually feel
kind of bad that the happens before
relation is so fundamental to this class
to the point where it's the very first
um
uh partial order that I talked about
because it's a weird one. Uh
right? It's not the partial order it's
it's not uh it's not a partial order
according to this definition. Um
The partial orders are going to come up
all the time uh in this course and we're
going to talk about some others as well.
Uh so
don't get confused, right? Uh the
happens before relation is not quite a
partial order according to this
definition. Instead, we say that it's an
it's it's an irreflexive uh partial
order.
Uh Uh but if we look at these other uh
these other other properties, certainly
transitivity is going to be true of the
happens before relation, right? Uh in
fact, it's right in the definition that
we wrote down. Uh so we know that that
checks out
um for happens before.
Um
And what about antisymmetry?
Well, so if you have uh
if you if you have two events, right?
Uh and you say that A happens before B
and also B happens before A, uh then A
equals B. Well, yeah, that one kind of
is is um that's another weird one in the
case of happens before uh
on a set of events in a distributed
system, right? Um because you're never
going to be in this situation where A
happens before B and also B happens
before A. Uh so this one the
antisymmetry part of the definition like
kind of also checks out uh
in a uh
in in in a in a sort of um
uh
uh in in in a uh
I I forget the word that I'm that I'm
looking for here. Um but it it it's it's
true in a sense. Um so that checks out.
Um but reflexivity doesn't. So uh so the
happens before relation is not a real
partial order. Have no fear that we will
talk about some real partial orders uh
later on.
So there there are lots and lots of
relations that are partial orders.
Um
and whenever you talk about uh a
relation being a partial order, um it
it's useful to to think about Okay, what
set are we dealing with, right? Um if
it's happens before, then the set we're
dealing with is the set of events,
right?
Uh
And so in the case of you know, this
picture that we drew before,
um
of a whole bunch of
events happening in this system, uh then
the set that we're talking about is uh
Q X S Y T Z U V P R, right? That's the
set of events for this particular
execution.
Um
and the the the relation relating these
events,
um
if it's going to be a partial order,
then it then it has to have these these
properties. Um
So
as we said, for happens before,
uh we took the easy one first, right?
Transitivity. Um the happens before
relation is transitive. It's right there
in the definition. Um
Antisymmetry, now I remember the word
that I was trying to say before. It's
kind of vacuously true, right? Um
Vacuously is the word that I was looking
for before.
But for reflexivity,
that's not true because for that to be
true,
it would need to be the case that given
an event A, A happens before A.
So that's really not true because it's
not clear what it would mean for an
event to happen before itself.
So the happens before relation is is
actually not quite a partial order. Uh
it's what's known as an irreflexive
partial order.
Uh and when you're talking about these
irreflexive partial orders, um you often
don't uh use this
uh less than or equal to notation uh
to write down the binary relation in
them just to emphasize how irreflexive
they are. Uh instead, you might just
write less than instead of less than or
equal. And of course, for happens
before, we already have our own notation
for it uh which is this arrow.
So these X's and check marks that I'm
writing here, these just have to do with
the happens before relation because the
happens before relation is the first
partial order that we've looked at. Um
I'm talking about how these uh these
three properties that are supposed to be
true for partial orders, these two do
hold up for the happens before relation,
but this reflexivity one doesn't. And so
happens before is is not a true partial
order. Instead, it's what we think of as
an irreflexive partial order.
So that's it for today. Um next time,
we're going to continue and we're going
to actually talk about another example
of a partial order. Uh and I'll see you
on Monday.